Nancy Pelosi is inviting President Trump
to deliver the State of the Union
address in Congress on February 5th as
you know the speech was initially slated
for tomorrow but Pelosi rescinded her
invitation due to the partial government
shutdown which is now ended and we'll
have a lot more on that coming up in
just a few but first the 2020 Democratic
presidential primary already turning
into a circus Senator Kamala Harris
formerly launching or campaign where she
took shots at the president and pushed a
radical agenda I am running to declare
once and for all that health care is a
fundamental right and we will deliver
that right with Medicare for all I am
running to declare education is a
fundamental right and we will guarantee
that right with universal pre-k and
debt-free college and after calling for
a wealth tax senator Elizabeth Warren is
now publicly shaming the billionaire
owner of the Washington Redskins for
buying a new yacht and according to a
new report Hillary Clinton is telling
friends that she hasn't closed the door
on running again in 2020 but wait
there's more Democrats are freaking out
over former Starbucks CEO Howard Schultz
saying he could run for president as an
independent liberals fear a third party
candidate could hand Trump a second term
Schultz floating the idea on 60 minutes
I will run as a centrist independent
outside of the two-party system not only
the fact that this president is not
qualified to be the president but the
fact that both parties are consistently
not doing what's necessary on behalf of
the American people and president Trump
hitting back against Schultz on Twitter
saying he doesn't have the guts to run
all right Gregg a lot to pick through
here exciting
it's like 2016 all over again this is
gonna be hilarious they're right about
Schultz oh yeah that's the most
frightening aspect because politics has
to be binary you have to have
Republicans and Democrats you put in a
third variable it throws everything off
and then
allows one side to squeak through we saw
that with Perot so you have this
imbalance you can fix the balance though
if you have two independents like if you
have the green party and you have this
party green party libertarian right left
and then you have four and then it kind
of cancels each other out it's like it's
like sports you know you know each team
has the same number of teammates right
right doesn't matter as long as there's
a kamala okay that's the first time I'd
really heard her speak she has she
doesn't have much charisma you don't
think so I don't think so and she's
she's like an automaker who can build
only half a car so she has all the
promises other progressive promises that
everybody applause if you're naive you
applaud applaud but just have the other
half of the car like how do you get this
thing going how do you how do you how do
you pay for this stuff and that's most
progressives that's their flaw they can
only build half a car and it's the
easiest car to build if the promises and
then if you look at Liz Warren with the
yacht this is a purely adolescent belief
hey there's a rich person let's take his
stuff and sell it that's not how you do
a government that's not how you do how
you pay for a government it's kind of
sad that that's how primitive she is an
ironic the senator going after the owner
of the Washington Redskins I don't think
she was aware of that I don't think he
says none of the charisma to deliver do
you agree with that she's got a lot of
charisma compared to Gillibrand I'll say
that's true you know it's funny when you
watch their platforms you remember when
Obamacare was like a radical idea or
like when Obama in 2008 had that Joe the
Plumber a moment and it would spread the
wealth around we were all like Oh spread
the redistribution of wealth now you
have on the Democratic side blatant
socialists coming out Medicare for all
you know education free education the
green new deal and it's interesting to
me because they want stuff to be free
whether you're talking about education
or health care but they don't care about
the quality and the reason that they
can't talk about quality is because what
makes quality better in these industries
is actually the free market which they
actively oppose I just think it's really
interesting to look at what's happened
on the left and when President Obama was
talking about this fundamental
transformation of America so many of us
were saying
this gonna be a creeping normality
little by little more and more
government in your face and everyone was
saying no no no he really wants to
Obamacare and I said no he doesn't he
wants Medicare for all and he's
instituting Obamacare because he knows
it's gonna fall and that's what people
like Bernie Sanders are gonna rush in
with but the fact that this has become
the mainstream of the Democratic Party I
think should horrify moderate Democrats
more than any well they don't care about
paying for it that's not their concern
want what scares you most Schultz
getting in or Hillary Clinton getting
back oh I think it's just felt scary
yeah because I think that if you divide
the opposition potentially that
strengthens then what is really you know
front we'll talk about this next buck
but Trump's poll numbers are not great
even by the best measure so in terms of
who would support him in turn you also
have a shrinking number of people who
identify as Republicans so when you say
Oh Republicans still support Trump
overwhelmingly although it's drifted a
little bit it's a smaller group but if
you should take away a percentage of the
people who were opposed to Trump so it's
back in independent like Schultz who has
lots of money that's big trouble and
that's why I think you've seen Michael
Bloomberg the former mayor of New York
say he will not run as an independent
and you I think it'll maybe was Greg who
mentioned you know what happened with
Ross Perot back in 92 you could go back
to people like John Anderson or come
forward to people you know it just
strikes me that you see these people
like in 2000 you know people said native
if Nader had had not been there we would
had a different president right in
Florida right but I must say I when I
hear you say you don't think camel-hair
Kamala Harris has charisma or doesn't
have a plan wait a minute the deficits
exploding under someone who had no way
of saying she wants here's how I care
for you education what I'm just saying
Trump said oh you know what I'm gonna
cut taxes radically I'm gonna drop the
deficit the deficits exploded and I
don't hear Republicans saying a word
because no matter what you do whether
you raise taxes or cut them it doesn't
matter of course these are getting money
back to the collar that we are losing
money on that tax cut and it's not
nothing
the American people government is a
people this whole Howard Schultz
discussion is fascinating to me because
of course you were talking about Ross
Perot got almost 19 percent of the vote
we've had I look this up today since
1788 we've had 58 presidential elections
where the third-party candidate won
somewhere roughly around five percent of
the vote on average so what the
Democrats are saying is why would you
run you can't win anything in the
electoral college you can't win but what
this could possibly be and I think we
may be shaping up for this is one of
those realigning election elections in
American history you know you have these
like in 1912 with the Progressive Party
actually got more votes in the
Republican Party for president in that
election so could we have a moment
between Trump's popularity between
Howard Schultz running between 30
Democrats needing or realigned American
politics you need to have for a great
weight if you have three you're gonna
end up it's gonna be a two-to-one thing
so you got out four or six it has to be
an even number right now Schultz is a
Democrat he's saying he's an independent
centrist he's much more of a Democrat
than he is a Republican and that's why
these Democrats are freaking also on a
book tour this guy so he's going out
there and he wants to sell his book and
he knows if he says he's running for
president he's gonna get a lot of
attention but one you know the deficit
you you can't do anything about the
deficit unless you look at entitlement
reform you really think that you're
gonna get you certainly can't do
something about revenue listen if you if
you didn't go to every axis you wouldn't
boost the everybody's wind up with an
economy that was sinking and you would
still have all that spending general
Krantz want to spend more money on
Medicare for all which they can't afford
at all other words we can spend money to
give millionaires a tax break well we
can't spend on people we don't let's not
spend it on people who are sick
Republicans you sick people you know
what you know it's done more for the
sick or any government that's why that's
why we hook it up without health market
either way that's the season have been
cured by the free market by the way
that's why now Obamacare is popular with
the American people one final thought on
this
you know that that in fact perot got 19%
of the vote yeah that's something to
remember that you don't spend money on a
tax cut and it's not how it works